what's the proudest moment of your
directing career well I I don't know
what my proudest moment is I know what
the films that I am proud of and I think
equally there's no I think this made
film I made in australia wake in fright
the apprenticeship of duddy kravitz with
richard dreyfuss with nick nolte north
dallas 40 waken of first blood with
sylvester stallone and those are the
film's i think and also in terms of
comedy weekend at Bernie's people always
ask you how come you to all the genres
don't you I said I do films that I love
and I'm interested in I've i think that
the you have to a film takes a long time
to come to 48 rhetorician and you'll
believe the preparation and the shooting
and the editing is a long run our
process and I think that you have to
really be passionate about what you're
doing that you really love I'm never
gonna film I didn't allow and didn't
didn't want to make so I'm proud of them
all these are just ones that her let's
stick out a little bit but I'm proud of
every time I make because I cared about
it someone left I made them more
successful than others some of them were
my black sometimes my lack of ability to
realize them as fully as I wish to but I
think you've got a care so passionately
about making a film because it takes
such a long time and there's also two
challenges there's time get off to get
off the set tonight darling Ted finished
agency I'll do my best hit them in so
you have to create something and it's
sometimes yet to just your vision of it
in order to get after said you
understand films have you made for
certain amount of money you can't be
capricious well I don't care so now we
can come back tomorrow some directors
are capable of I've never been there
cable of that I feel that you know if
you commit yourself you given this
amount of time to make this object you
should stick with it but and i think
that there's so many
and I think so many distractions people
it is when you're shooting a film so
many people here to distract you from
your vision of it in just like i did it
and i have this visit i do it like this
you know and sometimes people producers
try to change your mind about things and
i listened that's not that I'm
impervious sometimes it great ideas
comes I've had I've had a stagehand come
tell me great oh that's very good thanks
very much I'm going to get the credit
for that but on the whole grid produces
Robert lantau sywert I did I did
Joshua's N&R with him he was a great
producing as much as he he would makes
he had an intelligent suggestions they
were always intelligent and they were
never stupid right and then ever adults
and pissing contest I'm produces one
indulgent pissing contest with you and
he never did that and he make suggestion
if I made the slightest move no Ted it
just just an idea if you don't like it
don't do it but he always had something
provocative about this obsession so then
the good producers do that Socrates as I
say connect destructively to and you so
you need you need your deep commitment
if you're doing it just for the money
you have no moral basis for what you
like what you're doing because given the
money can we do this is what it'll be
more attractive to the audience if he
did yeah sure if you're doing for me but
I said I don't know because I I do it
because I want to do it and I know I
want to keep the artistic integrity
you